today both Secretary of State Anthony
blinkin and Homeland Security secretary
Alejandro mayorcas traveled to Mexico
City to beg Mexico's president to do
something anything to stop the massive
flow of immigrants constantly traveling
north through the country Mexican
president uel Lopez oor predicted the
failures of the Biden presidency from
the very beginning you may not remember
this but this is 2021 oor this is
Mexico's president described just how
migrants viewed president Biden he said
quote they see him as the migrant
president and so many feel they're going
to reach the United States and voila
they have in record numbers he was right
and at today's meeting with Mexico's
president noticeably missing was Biden's
borders are kamla Harris she's on a
leisurely trip to California and won't
return to the office until January 3rd
here now with reaction former ice
director and Fox News contributor Tom
Homan he's an expert on all of this
along along with Florida Congressman
Byron Donalds who has put forward
legislation to stop what we're seeing at
the southern border you know let me
start with you Congressman Donald's I'm
sick and tired of hearing people say
Republicans do not have a plan you
passed hr2 you did your job in the house
let's scroll it for our viewers here are
all of the things in hr2 that
Republicans have done and you can read
it as we go along security fencing
22,000 minimum border border patrol
agents and much more
Congressman well look first of all Kayla
it's great to be with you you're
absolutely correct House Republicans
have a plan we've had one for a very
long time I have a plan it adds to this
it creates actually an exit biometric
system something that 911 Commission
recommended that we do post 911 the
federal government still hasn't
completed that work but this is bigger
than that you have an Administration Joe
Biden KLA Harris and everybody else they
do not want to do the simple job of
securing the Border and so now when you
have a massive catastrophe with they
which they created now they're going
down to Mexico to see what can be done
the answer is simple do follow the House
Republicans hr2 it's the plan and let me
be very clear we've been telling this to
the Democrats and the Senate and Joe
Biden don't even talk to us about
Ukraine until the southern border is
secured secure America first then we can
have conversations about everything else
but this must be done it simply cannot
wait you know Tom Homan you and I both
worked for a former president president
Trump who got action from Mexico he said
you're getting tariffs unless you secure
the border and the Mexican president did
just that since sent 6,000 troops there
to the Border what do you think when you
see a meeting that went on today and
zero deliverables from Mexico to be
announced they don't need any more
meetings this meetings doesn't mean
Squat and you're right president Trump
go go didn't go to Mexico and beg for
help he didn't go to Central America and
beg for help he didn't give him millions
of dollars this Administration is given
Mexico Millions upon millions of dollars
they've given Central America millions
of dollars President Trump was a game
changer he didn't he didn't give him a
DME well he told Mexico you going to put
military in a Southern border northern
border you're going to participate in
remain in Mexico program you're going to
participate in the third safe country
agreement if you don't I'll tear up the
hell out of you and they came to the
table within Days Central America he
told me the same thing I'm not going to
pay to create opportunity zones down
there the money goes to the corrupt
people and never gets where it needs to
go I tell I'm going to do I'm going to
take all inter International Aid away
and they came to the table and look this
if this this Administration is serious
about securing the border which are not
they haven't done a single thing to slow
the flow it's easy dust off the Trump
plans we proved it work it's not even a
question will these policies work we
proved it work anybody go to cbp.gov
look at the numbers the last two years
under Trump the most secure Border in my
career three and A2 decades the the data
is clear illegal immigration at a 45
year law we proved it worked if they
want to secure the Border they have the
plan brush it off and put it in
place amen I couldn't say it any better
myself and Congressman that plan is
embodied in hr2 we know Senators met
today trying to craft a plan with
foreign aid combined with immigration
measures what do you think's going to be
acceptable to the house anything short
of hr2 or you guys need hr2 in there
what's accept acceptable to the house is
hr2 it's simple stuff we know it works
what we're not going to do is negotiate
against ourself for some ham-handed deal
that gets negotiated in the Senate we
have seen Senate negotiations occur in
this country before they basically are
weak sauce not worth the paper that
they're printed on the politicians in DC
say oh this is great look at what we did
America and then the reality hits home
that nothing really changed hr2 is the
starting point the Senators can
negotiate all they want but nothing's
moving through the house without
hr2 you know Tom and where does this end
you've got 15,000 migrants heading you
have this Caravan you have Chinese
Nationals is there going to ever be a
wakeup call I mean even politics
Democrats have said Biden you need to do
something we showed you the CNN
clip first of all let me footstop for
the congressman just said hr2 needs to
be passed fully 100% of it CU it's a
great plan
because it it it has a lot of the Trump
policies in it hr2 fully or nothing no
deal and I'm shocked that the Democrats
are willing to let Ukraine and Israel
suffer because they want an open border
so badly look these 15,000 they're going
to be processed going to be released in
the United States it's catching release
and when they when the cartel see
thousands being released every day that
just gives them a selling point we they
don't need a public affairs officers
they don't need a consultant to sell
their services the US government's
actions every day sells the services of
cartel tells because you cross the
border illegally you get released
quickly you get flown to the city of
your choice on tax Paradigm you get work
work authorization next five or seven
years we'll get in hotel room you get
three squares a day and free medical why
the hell wouldn't it come because we're
not enforcing law on the border Cala
Harris she she call her borar all she
wants she hasn't done a damn thing she
said I want to find the underlying
underlying reasons for this Mass
migration she just simply needs to walk
down the hall until the Oval Office and
she'll find the reason man's a across
the border because they were made
promises by this
Administration you know and Congressman
Donald's where's the president I mean
he's on vacation he sends Anthony
blankin off he sends my orcus off they
do nothing no deliverables zero he's on
vacation 40% of his
presidency I mean Kaye let's let's be
honest this man is the most
unaccountable president in American
history you combine that with being the
worst president in American history the
man is probably taking a nap as we speak
I know it's a little over 9 Eastern he's
already gone to bed we have a problem
America Joe Biden is awful at this job
he is not a leader and he is a radical
being led by radicals in that
Administration they all need to go and
for America listen Mean Tweets no Mean
Tweets let's get somebody back in the
White House who knows how to do the job
and execute and put our country first
that's president
Trump well I hope hope President Biden
enjoys that Beachside vacation wow
undeserved Congressman Donald's Tom
Homan thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else